(bouncy, energetic Christmas music)
(bouncy, happy jazz music)
- Hi, I'm Hannah,
and I'm addicted to Christmas sweaters.
My sweater collection started
probably six years ago.
I bought a sweater vest on
eBay and it smelled horrible,
but it was just the
funniest thing in the world,
and it snowballed into
this long-running joke
of just buying any
vintage Christmas sweater
I could get my hands on.
My mom joined in, and
together we have a collection
of upwards of 350.
I know I'm crazy.
I'll be the first one to
say, "I'm totally insane."
This is a good crazy.
It's fun.
I wear one every day of
the month of December.
And it makes people happy.
I walk down the street
and people are like,
"That's a cool sweater."
The sweaters are so cool.
If you just spent the time
to just look through each one
and see how funny and cool they are.
I think it's awesome.
My idol, the only person I'd like to meet
if I could meet anyone in the world,
it would be Michael Simon.
He does the most brilliant designs,
the most in your face,
disgusting Christmas barf
all over everything.
Wherever you go in a
Michael Simon sweater,
like people know that you're there
because they can sense the Christmas
coming off your sweater.
If I had to guess how
much money we've spent
on Christmas sweaters,
it's probably about $2,000.
We have a few sweaters that
are going for about $500 now.
The character ones are insanely popular,
so I think we could probably
triple what we spent
if we sold all of them.
But now we're kind of attached,
so I think we're gonna keep 'em all.
It's impossible to make
an ugly Christmas sweater.
Like the way you'd make it is,
"How do I make a really
nice Christmas sweater?"
And that's what these are.
When you see the ones now
that are trying to be ugly,
you can tell the difference.
It's not authentic.
It's not an actual Christmas sweater
with the intent of
looking really glamorous.
I like that this is a thing
that's brought my mom and I
really close.
Literally the only reason we
have it is because it makes
people happy.
So, that's probably my favorite
part about owning all these.
The mailman really, really
hated my mom for a while,
because he'd come with just
this giant bin full of packages
'cause we'd have like 15
sweaters coming at a time
on the reg.
(laughter)
(creaking)